Quelques jours seulement avant leur suicide
le 30 avril 1945,
Adolf Hitler et Eva Braun terminés
la destruction de toutes leurs archives.
Hitler ne voulait rien laisser derrière lui.
Les historiens pensaient avoir consulté
toutes les archives accessibles existantes.
Soixante-dix ans plus tard,
merci au Commandant Raymond Rose,
un officier français, aujourd'hui décédé,
et un collectionneur privé,
nouvelles archives politiques et personnelles
d'importance historique
ont été révélés pour la première fois.
Ces documents uniques
maintenant, mettons l'accent beaucoup plus clairement
certains moments cruciaux
dans les derniers jours d'Hitler.
Quelle était l’ambiance dans le bunker ?
Le Führer gardait-il encore espoir
d'un revers militaire ?
Y a-t-il des preuves matérielles
de l'affaire
entre Hitler et Eva Braun ?
Quand exactement lui et son compagnon ont-ils
décider de se suicider ?
Göring avait-il vraiment l'intention de prendre le pouvoir
dans les derniers jours du Reich ?
Le Troisième Reich vient d'être détruit.
Berlin, centre névralgique de l'Allemagne nazie,
n'est qu'un tas de ruines.
Il ne reste plus rien de cette capitale
ça depuis quelques années
fait trembler le monde.
Les Occidentaux arriveraient
et prendre possession
de leur zone d'occupation
à Berlin en juin.
Ensuite, ils ont dû visiter le bunker.
Des milliers de personnes ont visité,
impatient d'avoir un aperçu
de ce que les Soviétiques appelaient :
le tueur de bêtes.
Tout le monde voulait voir où Hitler était mort.
D’abord un cortège de personnalités.
Puis sont venus les membres
des Américains, des Britanniques, des Français,
et les forces d'occupation soviétiques,
tous viennent visiter le bunker.
Parmi les militaires
qui a visité le bunker
était un groupe d'officiers français.
Dans l'après-midi du 25 novembre 1945,
Commandant Raymond Rose
est entré ce qui restait
de la Chancellerie d'Hitler,
par l'entrée principale de la Voss-Strasse.
Ils s'étaient préparés pour cette expédition.
Comme leurs camarades avant eux,
ils espéraient faire quelques découvertes.
Le commandant Rose a décrit son incursion
dans le sous-sol
du dernier quartier général d'Hitler.
Il a dessiné trois cartes de son itinéraire
et l'endroit où il a trouvé
les documents du Führer.
Tout ce qui reste
de la Chancellerie du Führer
sont les murs et les pièces vides
encombré de meubles renversés,
portant encore les traces du pillage.
La maison est ouverte à tous.
Dans le trou principal éclairé par des torches électriques,
tu cherches une petite porte cachée,
qui mène à un escalier de huit marches,
menant à un deuxième escalier plus large,
qui mène à une vaste pièce
avec des colonnes carrées.
Bien que souterraine, cette pièce est décorée
avec autant de soin que n'importe quelle salle de cérémonie.
Puis au fond
de cette pièce déjà sombre,
tu dois trouver une porte en fer
avec des fleurs murales.
Ouvrez-le et allez plus profondément sous terre,
en bas d'un escalier droit et étroit
avec exactement 26 étapes.
Là tu peux voir un horrible gâchis
de chaises et de tables retournées.
Cire de bougie, traces d'incendie
dont l'ambition a été étouffée.
Le sol est recouvert d'une masse incroyable
de papiers de toutes sortes :
lettres administratives, registres,
cahiers feuilletés à la main
ça pendant sept mois
j'avais cherché frénétiquement
pour le secret de la bonne fortune
m'avait été confié.
Dans la pièce la plus reculée,
J'ai trouvé les documents qui établissent
que Hitler voulait rester,
quoi qu'il arrive, Maître,
contre toute attente, même malgré les événements.
Le petit groupe français a réalisé un grand
découverte historique sans s'en rendre compte.
Cependant, plus de 70 ans plus tard,
un collectionneur français, un passionné
pour cette page sombre de l'histoire,
acquis commandant
Les documents de Raymond Rose.
À un moment donné
il a récupéré les documents
qui étaient sur une armoire
et les a ramenés.
Je dirais que c'était juste après ça
que nous avons réalisé
la signification historique
de ces documents.
Il a donc demandé la permission de les garder,
qui a été accordé,
et il a gardé ces documents toute sa vie.
Je ne pense pas qu'il en ait bénéficié
du recul historique.
Pour lui, c'était un acte beaucoup plus émotionnel
parce que, d'une certaine manière,
il était un acteur de l'histoire.
Pour comprendre l'incalculable
importance des documents historiques,
il faut revoir l'histoire
des derniers jours d'Adolf Hitler.
Mi-avril, avec l'Armée rouge
à pas plus de 100 kilomètres de Berlin.
Les restes de la division allemande,
environ un demi-million d'hommes et 900 chars
se retiraient
devant le rouleau compresseur russe.
Sur 200 kilomètres,
le front cédait.
Le Reich était à genoux,
et les bombardiers alliés
frappaient Berlin.
Tous les dix jours apportait un raid de jour
par les Américains,
mais chaque nuit, des descentes de harcèlement
par les moustiques britanniques.
Cela signifiait que les gens étaient constamment
sous les escaliers et dans les caves,
occupé à se réfugier dans les refuges,
Hitler, comme les autres
3 millions de Berlinois.
Donc tout le monde était épuisé.
En fait, c'est pourquoi les Britanniques
intensifié les raids.
À un moment donné,
le bombardement est devenu si grand
qu'il a décidé de déménager.
Il a donc emménagé définitivement dans le bunker.
Pour les Allemands désespérés,
l'attente du dernier acte de la tragédie
semblait interminable.
La radio a diffusé la dernière émission en direct
de l'Orchestre Philharmonique de Berlin,
le final de Richard Wagner
Le Crépuscule des Dieux.
Hitler s'est enfermé dans son abri,
quelques centaines de mètres
de la porte de Brandebourg
sous les jardins de la Chancellerie
dans le quartier du gouvernement central.
De ce bunker,
il dirigea les dernières opérations militaires.
Pour une meilleure visualisation
des projets à la Chancellerie,
et le bunker d'Hitler,
ils ont été reconstitués en 3D.
Ce qu'on appelle le bunker du Führer
a été construite sur deux niveaux.
Le premier en 1936 sous partie
de la Chancellerie du Reich.
Le deuxième niveau a été construit en 1943 et 44,
quand c'est devenu clair
que l'épaisseur du plafond de 1,6 mètres
n'était pas suffisant pour résister
Le plus puissant
Bombes américaines et britanniques.
Le bunker était une construction
de dimensions relativement petites.
Espace vital
avait été sacrifié à la robustesse.
C'était absolument énorme,
coffrage à béton.
Hitler voulait en être sûr
qu'il pourrait rester à Berlin
et contrôler les événements à partir de là.
Il avait toujours peur
d'être loin de Berlin,
probablement depuis la tentative
de juillet 1944
renverser le gouvernement nazi
ainsi que l'assassiner,
et Berlin allait
être le pouvoir central.
Hitler et Albert Speer,
son architecte et ministre de l'armement,
j'ai pensé à tout pour le bunker.
Le Führer devait pouvoir y vivre
pendant quelque temps avec ses gardes,
à l’abri de toute attaque aérienne.
[Audio parlé en allemand]
Dans cette partie du bunker,
Hitler avait prévu ou ordonné un espace,
séparé du reste.
Un appartement privé de quatre petites pièces.
Dans l'autre partie du bunker
il y avait plus de chambres, mais aucune intimité.
Hitler en avait réservé trois
des pièces absolument minuscules pour lui-même,
et une pièce attenante
pour sa maîtresse, Eva Braun,
les deux partageant une petite salle de bain.
Il y avait aussi une petite salle de réunion,
où deux fois par jour
Hitler assisterait aux réunions
examiner la situation militaire
avec ses conseillers principaux.
Le bunker était une cave
enterré à sept mètres sous terre.
Des ajustements spéciaux ont été effectués
pour le confort d'Hitler
et son entourage.
Il y a évidemment une ambiance morose.
L'endroit en lui-même est absolument lamentable.
Le bunker de coffrage en béton
était situé sur la nappe phréatique
de la rivière Spree, qui coulait à proximité.
C'est donc un endroit
qui suinte constamment.
Le sol est pompé en continu,
et il fait froid.
Il y a un système de ventilation mécanique,
et tu peux entendre le ventilateur tout le temps
et ça te donne mal à la tête.
C'est vraiment un endroit sordide.
Dans ce cadre,
Hitler n'était pas à son meilleur niveau.
Il a émis des ordres contradictoires.
Le Dr Morell, son médecin,
lui a fait une injection quotidienne
de glucose et de vitamines,
et il prenait un certain nombre de drogues.
N'importe lequel des officiers
qui a vu Hitler à ce moment-là,
et j'en ai interviewé plusieurs,
ont été secoués à son retour
pour voir dans quel état il se trouvait.
Ses mains tremblaient,
il avait l'air absolument blanc.
Il avait l'air d'être au moins
10 à 15 ans de plus qu'il ne l'était réellement.
Ils étaient consternés, mais aussi inquiets
sur sa stabilité mentale.
Vous pouvez voir qu'il était très délabré,
et en fait à un stade avancé
de la maladie de Parkinson.
Il était penché, traînant les pieds,
il ne pouvait pas contrôler son bras gauche.
Il doit donc le tenir avec sa main droite
à cause des secousses spasmodiques.
Hitler avait un effectif d'environ 30 personnes
pour que le bunker continue de fonctionner.
Il était servi par ses gardes personnels,
les techniciens du bunker,
et le personnel des communications.
Ce que tu as ici
est le rassemblement final du Reich.
En d'autres termes, Goebbels,
qui a installé sa famille dans le bunker,
Bormann,
l'indispensable secrétaire personnelle,
et les secrétaires.
Contre la volonté d'Hitler,
son compagnon secret
le rejoignit dans le bunker.
Dans la collection privée, nous avons trouvé
étaient deux lettres extrêmement importantes
d'Eva Braun.
Voici les originaux.
C'est la première fois qu'ils sont montrés,
ses deux dernières lettres.
Le premier est daté du 19 avril 1945,
adressée à sa meilleure amie,
Herta Schneider, restée en Bavière.
Les secrétaires et Ishoot tous les jours
avec des armes de poing,
et nous sommes déjà si compétents
qu'aucun homme n'ose rivaliser avec nous.
J'ai passé pratiquement toute ma vie
dans cet abri anti-aérien.
Vous pouvez imaginer à quel point il est difficile de dormir.
Cependant, je suis très heureux
être près de lui en ce moment.
Finalement, dit-elle, je resterai avec lui.
C'est la tragédie d'Eva Braun,
être une petite fille extrêmement romantique
qui était beaucoup plus jeune que lui
et qui tout au long de l'affaire avec Hitler,
n'avait peur que d'une chose : le perdre.
En fait, elle a tenté de se suicider
au début de leur relation.
Hitler a eu peur et l'a gardée.
Alors pour elle, ça, d'une certaine manière,
formalise la relation,
le fait de montrer qu'elle restera
à ses côtés jusqu'au bout.
Cette lettre nous donne également des informations clés
sur l'humeur d'Hitler
à la veille de son 56e anniversaire.
Cette lettre est intéressante,
car il montre l'atmosphère dans le bunker.
Nous pouvons encore voir une lueur d’espoir.
Il ne se passe pas un jour sans qu'on me supplie
se réfugier au Berghof en Bavière,
mais jusqu'à présent, j'ai toujours gagné.
Aujourd'hui, toute communication est impossible,
mais je suis profondément convaincu
que tout reviendra à nouveau,
et il a plus d'espoir que jamais.
Pourtant, à 3 heures du matin le 20 avril,
une triste sirène retentit,
une sirène que les Berlinois
je n'avais jamais entendu parler auparavant,
un signal à tous
qu'une nouvelle épreuve était sur le point de commencer.
Chars de l'Armée rouge
ont été aperçus en banlieue.
Le 20 avril a effectivement été un moment clé
symboliquement puisque c'était l'anniversaire d'Hitler,
et alors que les Soviétiques commençaient à envahir Berlin.
Donc le problème pour Hitler
était de savoir s'il fallait rester dans la ville ou fuir.
A partir du 20,
c'est devenu un problème urgent
comme la menace
d'être encerclé a augmenté,
et le dernier mur de troupes s'effondre.
Ce qu'il faut faire?
Courir ou se battre ?
Ce jour-là, à 15 heures,
Hitler a fait son dernier voyage à l'extérieur.
Au sommet des marches du bunker
dans les jardins de la Chancellerie,
il a reçu l'anniversaire
vœux d’une délégation SS.
Hitler reçut notamment,
une délégation des Jeunesses hitlériennes,
la plus jeune réserve de son armée.
C'étaient les enfants
qui étaient envoyés en première ligne
mourir en défendant Berlin.
Il voulait honorer
et récompenser les plus courageux d'entre eux.
Le bras gauche d'Hitler
a été saisi par les secousses.
Il a serré la main de tout le monde,
tapoter la joue des jeunes
il envoyait à leur mort
dans les unités antichar.
Le plus jeune avait 11 ans,
l'âge auquel les enfants changeaient d'école
du junior au secondaire.
Il est vraiment petit, environ 1,4 mètres,
et il porte un uniforme des Jeunesses hitlériennes.
A 16h00,
juste avant le briefing militaire,
le Führer a reçu des vœux d'anniversaire
de la part des hauts responsables de son parti.
Himmler, Ribbentrop,
Bormann, Dönitz, Keitel, Jodl,
Speer et Göring.
Tous ses fidèles étaient là,
offrant mes félicitations,
mais Hitler a tout accepté
à contrecœur,
comme il l'était de toute évidence
pas d'humeur à fêter son anniversaire.
Je pense que le 20 avril 1945
était probablement l'un des plus grotesques
des fêtes d'anniversaire qu'on pourrait imaginer.
Ici tu avais Göring ce matin-là
qui avait explosé
son célèbre château de Carinhall
s'assurer que
les Russes ne pourraient jamais l'avoir,
et puis tous ses trésors pillés,
les photos et tout,
ont été emmenés dans un convoi
des camions de la Luftwaffe vers le sud.
Puis il arrive,
et il arrive avec Keitel,
et tous les autres dirigeants nazis.
La plupart d’entre eux, bien sûr, étaient désespérés
avoir l'autorisation de quitter Berlin
parce qu'ils savaient que la ville était condamnée.
Beaucoup d'entre eux ont tenté de persuader Hitler
partir, pas nécessairement pour le sauver,
mais uniquement pour leur donner
la permission de se quitter.
Ce jour-là, sa maîtresse,
Eva Braun lui a fait un cadeau,
une photographie signée.
Nous l'avons trouvée présente.
C'est une pièce exceptionnelle,
jamais révélé au public,
avec une histoire remarquable en pièce jointe.
Pendant des années après la guerre,
la photographie et son cadre
est resté avec la sœur d'Eva, Gretl.
Ce n'est que lorsque la famille Braun s'en est débarrassée,
a fait un amateur aux yeux perçants
faire la découverte.
Cette dédicace
est la preuve physique unique
de l'amour d'Eva Braun pour Hitler.
Tous les autres documents,
comme leur correspondance personnelle,
ont été détruits
dans les derniers jours de la guerre.
Elle lui donne une photo dédicacée
d'elle-même dans un cadre argenté
qui porte en effet son monogramme,
un club conçu par Albert Speer.
La photo porte l'inscription suivante
"A mon Führer, de la part de ta fidèle, Eva."
C'est très révélateur
de la mentalité d'Eva Braun
et de ce qu'elle cherche,
comme elle n'utilise pas son nom,
mais plutôt à « mon Führer »
ce qui implique une importance politique,
et plus particulièrement,
elle utilise le mot fidèle.
C'est un moment où tout le monde
commence à suivre son propre chemin,
et elle veut marquer
sa fidélité à Adolf Hitler
et le fait qu'elle soit revenue.
Hitler a accepté le cadeau d'elle
qui l'avait rejoint dans ses heures les plus sombres.
Il avait transformé Eva Braun
dans un secret d'État pour la simple raison
qu'il pensait qu'il,
le leader du peuple allemand,
ne pouvait en aucun cas prendre femme,
comme ça motiverait toutes les autres femmes
qui voulait être avec lui au désespoir.
En même temps,
il le devait à son pays,
à ce qu'il considérait comme la notion
de son pays de ne pas prendre femme,
et c'est pourquoi c'était devenu
un secret absolu.
Il refuse de se réfugier dans les Alpes,
où étaient postées les troupes d’élite.
Tout le monde le pressait d'aller en Bavière,
à la soi-disant forteresse alpine,
où de grandes fortifications
et des bunkers avaient été construits,
dans la région de l'Obersalzberg.
La propagande allemande
essayé de convaincre les Alliés
ils installaient un refuge alpin,
où des éléments fanatiques des SS
pourrait tenir tête aux Alliés
depuis longtemps encore.
Rien de tout cela n’existait, c’était juste du bluff.
Mais c'était de la propagande
qu'Eisenhower croyait évidemment,
et cela a eu un impact militaire majeur
comme une grande partie des forces américaines
ont été envoyés vers le sud en direction de Munich
et les Alpes au lieu de se diriger vers l'est.
Hitler savait qu’il n’existait pas de refuge alpin.
Il savait qu'il retardait le mauvais jour
et j'ai décidé qu'il valait mieux mourir
dans une scène apocalyptique wagnérienne mise en scène
à Berlin
entouré de ses dernières troupes.
Speer lui avait donné l'idée,
une idée très cinématographique
que le Götterdämmerung à Berlin,
ce serait dramatique,
à Berchtesgaden,
il n'y en aurait pas
de la même qualité dramatique.
Contre l'avis de tout son staff
et ses proches,
Hitler décide de rester à Berlin.
La victoire ou la mort.
Sa dernière bataille
aurait lieu dans sa capitale.
L'anniversaire s'est terminé ce soir-là
avec le dernier raid aérien allié sur Berlin.
Tôt le matin du 21 avril,
pour la première fois
depuis le début de la guerre,
Obus d'artillerie soviétique
pleuvait sur la ville stupéfaite.
C'était le scénario
que personne n'avait prévu,
une bataille pour Berlin.
Il était évident qu'Hitler voulait faire
une sorte de suite de Stalingrad.
Il se souvenait, tout comme Goebbels,
qu'il voyait chaque nuit,
et qui lui rappelait constamment
de ce précédent,
qu'à terme, une bataille urbaine majeure
pourrait provoquer un tournant dans la guerre.
Staline, en accord avec Hitler,
a décidé que symboliquement,
prendre Berlin avait du sens.
Celui qui a pris Berlin
pour la postérité et pour l'éternité
serait le véritable vainqueur du Reich.
Après le bombardement,
les différentes unités de l'armée soviétique
a commencé à encercler Berlin.
Ils faisaient dix kilomètres
du centre ville.
Les premiers soldats soviétiques
est entré dans le centre de la capitale allemande.
Staline a nommé le Reichstag
comme cible symbolique.
A ce stade de l’avancée russe,
Hitler n'était pas encore sa priorité.
De plus, les services de renseignement soviétiques
Je ne savais pas où était Hitler.
Il a peut-être déjà pris la fuite.
En fait, il était là,
quelques mètres sous terre dans le bunker,
essayer de planifier une contre-offensive.
Tout changeait
d'un instant à l'autre,
et bien sûr, les briefings eux-mêmes
faire face aux forces
n'avait aucun lien avec la réalité.
Je veux dire, Hitler
je regardais encore une fois les cartes,
je disais que c'est une armée,
c'est une division, ou autre chose,
alors qu'en fait, ils consistaient simplement,
souvent, de très peu d’hommes.
Enfermé dans son bunker.
Hitler avait encore trois corps d'armée
autour de Berlin,
Neuvième armée du général Busse
au sud-est,
l'unité Steiner au nord
et la 12e armée
au sud-ouest de la ville.
Ils n'avaient pas de véhicules blindés,
et pas de canons antichar.
Il s'agissait principalement de jeunes soldats,
très enthousiaste,
qui étaient prêts à se battre jusqu'au bout,
mais je n'avais tout simplement pas les armes.
L'idée que d'une manière ou d'une autre
la 12e armée pourrait s'engager
avec la Neuvième Armée venant de l'Est,
et faire une contre-attaque combinée
contre les Russes
était, encore une fois, typique du fantasme d'Hitler.
Hitler a continué à donner des ordres,
comme si ces trois forces pouvaient concevoir
une sorte de mouvement concentrique
qui leur a permis de contre-encercler
les armées soviétiques.
Aucune contre-offensive n’a fonctionné.
Les Allemands reculaient dans tous les domaines.
Hitler n'a pas compris
pourquoi les troupes déplaçaient-il sur une carte
n'étaient pas percés.
Ce jour-là, pour la première fois depuis des lustres,
Hitler a perdu son sang-froid
Devant tout le monde.
Il a piqué une crise en criant : "J'abandonne,
tout est perdu, c'est la fin !"
C'était à ce moment-là que tout le monde autour de lui
réalisé qu'il n'avait pas de solution,
pas de plan, pas d'espoir,
et que tout était vraiment perdu.
Eva Braun a partagé son désespoir avec Hitler.
Elle l'a décrit
dans ce document exceptionnel.
Également révélé pour la première fois.
sa dernière lettre, écrite le 22 avril,
a été adressé
à sa meilleure amie, Herta Schneider.
Ce seront probablement mes dernières lignes,
et mon dernier signe de vie.
Je n'ose pas écrire à Gretl,
alors brise-le-lui doucement.
Ils ont tous deux décidé de se suicider.
C'était déjà très important,
comme Hitler ne l'a pas annoncé
à son entourage le 22 avril.
Ils l'annonceraient plus tard.
Dans tous les cas,
elle a expliqué en détail dans la lettre
pourquoi tous deux se sont suicidés.
"Je t'enverrai mes bijoux et je te demanderai
pour le distribuer selon ma volonté.
"Je ne peux pas te décrire ce que je ressens"
"et ce que je souffre
personnellement pour le Führer."
"Je n'arrive pas à comprendre comment tout
peut juste finir de cette façon, "
"mais nous ne pouvons croire en aucun Dieu."
"Je crains que la fin ne soit proche,
Je mourrai comme j'ai vécu."
"Gardez cette lettre pour vous
jusqu'à ce que vous entendiez parler de notre sort.
"Je sais que je t'en demande beaucoup,
mais tu es courageux.
Elle dit qu'elle lui enverra des bijoux
en même temps
et lui demande de s'assurer qu'elle le fera…
Elle avait été très claire,
et un testament très détaillé.
Elle lui a demandé de s'assurer qu'elle
a été exécuté
jusque dans les moindres détails.
Cette lettre, le Testament,
et les bijoux d'Eva Braun
partit pour la Bavière le même jour.
Pendant ce temps, le 22 au soir,
Hitler a fait une déclaration
aux membres de son équipe,
qui comprenait le représentant de Göring.
Je passe les rênes maintenant, c'est fini.
Mon successeur peut y veiller.
Göring peut le faire.
En 1939 et 1941,
Le maréchal Göring avait été nommé
le successeur potentiel par décret,
mais pour être appliqué,
les décrets requis
la signature du Führer
pour les rendre officiels.
Les paroles d'Hitler ont été rapportées à Göring,
installé en Bavière,
où il s'était réfugié
avec une partie de son équipe
et l'un de ses conseillers, Hans Lammers.
Prudent, Göring, l'héritier présomptif,
était au début douteux.
Est-ce que le décret du Führer
me nommant son successeur en 1939,
et encore en 1941, est-ce toujours valable ?
En a-t-il émis un autre depuis ?
Lammers a dit : "Non,
S'il y en avait eu un, je l'aurais su."
"Donc, c'est toujours valable."
Ils l'examinent.
Il y réfléchit et dit :
"Si le Führer avait dit cela
et je suis le prochain sur la liste",
"Qu'est-ce qu'on fait?"
Hermann Goering
j'ai pris le temps d'y réfléchir.
Il était déchiré
entre ses folies de grandeur
et la perspective de commettre
une énorme erreur politique.
Il a décidé de dormir dessus.
A Berlin, les bombardements se poursuivent.
A l'aube du 23 avril,
prendre toutes sortes de risques,
Albert Speer, architecte
et le ministre de l'armement d'Hitler,
retour à la capitale
et a été admis au bunker.
Eva Braun était heureuse,
pensant que maintenant elle avait réussi
pour persuader le Führer de partir.
Elle s’était malheureusement trompée.
Hitler a fait fortune en tant qu'architecte,
lui a donné accès
aux plus hautes fonctions de l'État,
mais il a fallu du courage
venir faire ses adieux.
Hitler lui a réservé un accueil plutôt cool,
mais compris.
Hitler n'était pas stupide.
Il pouvait voir tout le monde autour de lui
était en train de renflouer.
Albert Speer a fait ses adieux
à l'homme qu'il admirait,
mais j'avais aussi une confession à faire,
de sa propre désobéissance.
Speer n'avait pas postulé
Le terrible ordre d'Hitler,
nécessitant la destruction totale
des infrastructures du Reich
avant l'Armée rouge
et les Alliés arrivèrent.
Speer a été profondément blessé
qu'Hitler ne lui a pas, au moins, montré
un peu plus d'affection ou d'intérêt
et je n'ai même pas montré aucun intérêt
quand il a avoué
à pratiquement un ordre, un acte de trahison.
Nous trouvons ici, dans ce dernier instant,
un écho à la relation privilégiée
entre les deux hommes.
Speer voulait lui dire.
En même temps,
il voulait voir une dernière fois,
l'homme pour lequel il ressentait très fort.
Hitler a peut-être vu, dans Speer,
une sorte de fils qu'il n'a jamais eu,
ce qui explique cette absence de réaction,
sa passivité face à ce que Speer avait dit.
D'autres ont été exécutés pour bien moins cher.
Hitler l'a laissé partir.
Dans l'après-midi du 23 avril 1945,
Hermann Goering
a finalement pris sa décision.
Il a écrit à Hitler à 17h43.
"Führer, es-tu d'accord,
suite à votre décision"
"de rester à ton poste de combat
dans la forteresse de Berlin,"
"que je devrais assumer le leadership
du Reich avec les pleins pouvoirs,"
"à la fois en interne et en externe ?"
Göring pensait…
En fait, il avait déjà fait
pas mal de contacts
pour tenter de relancer les pourparlers de paix.
Göring voulait être considéré comme l'homme
qui a apporté la paix en Allemagne,
et il a envoyé un télégramme à Hitler
dans le bunker, dans lequel il a dit :
que si Hitler n'avait montré aucun signe
de la vie avant 22h00 le 23 avril,
Göring comprendrait que cela signifie
il était le nouveau chancelier
et Hitler n'était plus en mesure
pour émettre des commandes.
Ce télégramme
et toute la correspondance suivante,
ont été tirés de documents
découvert dans le bunker d'Hitler
par le commandant Rose.
En tout, 13 lettres et télégrammes originaux
d'importance historique
qui nous permettent désormais de reconstruire précisément
l'échange final, extrêmement tendu
entre Hitler et Göring.
Puis il envoya un deuxième télégramme,
cette fois à Ribbentrop,
et probablement Keitel aussi, disant :
"Si le Führer ne répond pas",
"Viens me rejoindre à Berchtesgaden",
"ce qui veut dire que je prends le relais."
Il n'a absolument aucun sens
d'être déloyal envers Hitler.
Il réagit à une situation
où Hitler n'est plus
en mesure de gouverner l'Allemagne.
S'il devait le remplacer,
ce ne serait pour lui que temporaire.
Quelles que soient les intentions de Göring,
ce deuxième message lui coûterait cher.
Lorsqu'il fut remis à Hitler,
il était avec Goebbels et Bormann,
Les ennemis jurés de Göring.
Il avait sous-estimé, bien sûr,
la façon dont cela se jouerait immédiatement
entre les mains de son ennemi mortel Bormann
qui l'a immédiatement présenté
de telle manière à Hitler,
que Hitler ne pouvait que le voir
comme une véritable trahison.
Hitler était, à ce stade de la guerre,
absolument convaincu
que la seule raison pour laquelle ils perdaient
c'était parce qu'il avait été trahi partout.
Le soir même,
Hitler a envoyé une réponse cinglante
à Hermann Göring.
"Le décret n'entre en vigueur
quand je le ratifierai. »
"Il ne peut être question que je sois
privé de liberté d'action.
"Je vous interdit donc
entreprendre toute action de quelque nature que ce soit. »
Signé Adolf Hitler.
Sur la recommandation de Bormann,
son chef de cabinet personnel,
Hitler fit arrêter Göring.
À minuit 56 minutes,
le 24 avril,
Göring a répondu dans un long télégramme
dans lequel il a nié toute arrière-pensée.
"Je n'ai rien fait
en attendant votre réponse,"
"et soyez prêt à vous servir."
"Que Dieu te protèges.
Votre fidèle, Hermann Göring."
"Je t'en supplie, ne donne pas d'ordre à Frank
pour m'arrêter.
"Je te donne ma parole d'honneur
que j'ai strictement obéi à vos ordres.
Tard dans la matinée du 24,
Hitler a dicté
un autre télégramme à Göring.
"Ce télégramme personnellement signé
était sans équivoque."
"Vos actions constituent une trahison
d'une cause nationale,"
"et une telle conduite, haute trahison,
mérite la peine de mort. »
"Prendre en considération
vos grands services dans le passé, "
"Je vous offre une chance de démissionner,
en invoquant une maladie grave comme raison.
"Je vous ordonne de répondre immédiatement,
Oui ou non."
Dans les minutes qui suivirent, Göring
a répondu oui, à la demande du Führer.
Il a démissionné de toutes ses fonctions
pour des raisons de santé.
Cela marquait la succession au pouvoir,
d'un personnage sombre
appelé Martin Bormann,
son secrétaire depuis Rudolf Hess
s'était envolé pour la Grande-Bretagne en 1941.
Bormann a donné libre cours à la haine
il éprouvait pour certaines personnalités,
en fait, fléchissant ses nouveaux muscles.
Göring était dévasté,
mais cela ne suffisait pas à Bormann.
Bormann, qui avait le sien
centre de communication dans le bunker,
a profité de la disgrâce de Göring
pour avancer ses pions.
Sans en informer Hitler,
il a donné un dernier ordre
à l'officier chargé de le surveiller.
Bormann lui a ordonné de les exécuter
tout cela une fois Berlin tombé.
Ce scénario n'a pas été mis en œuvre
parce que le major SS,
qui avait reçu la mission,
quand Berlin est tombé,
je pensais que le meurtre
serait inutile.
Il n'a donc pas exécuté l'ordre.
Pourquoi a-t-il dit après la chute de Berlin ?
Il savait qu'Hitler ne serait pas en vie.
pour qu'il puisse régler ses comptes.
Sachant que Goebbels
suivrait Hitler, pensait-il,
"Si je peux aussi me débarrasser de Göring,
ça va juste me quitter.
Hitler n'était pas au courant
de ce qui se passait dans son dos,
et pour humilier encore plus Göring,
il l'a dépouillé de ses derniers pouvoirs.
Le 25 avril,
il a dicté son dernier message
à Göring, à son assistant.
"A la lumière de ton attitude infidèle
au peuple allemand, à moi-même,"
"et aux mesures envisagées,
Je t'ai exclu de la fête. »
Personnellement signé par Adolf Hitler.
Ce jour-là, il ordonna également la destruction
de toutes ses archives personnelles.
Ces documents
aurait dû être détruit,
mais dans la panique des derniers jours,
ils ont été miraculeusement oubliés.
Hitler avait brûlé
toutes ses archives personnelles,
qui comprendrait des éléments très importants
correspondance avec les chefs d'État.
Il a aussi brûlé tous les mémos militaires,
et il demanda à son adjudant Julius Schaub,
quitter le bunker, aller à Munich,
et brûle les archives
dans son appartement et à Berchtesgaden,
ce que Schaub fit dûment.
Il y a une préoccupation, un peu comme Goebbels,
un souci pour sa postérité.
Les combats se rapprochaient.
Heure après heure, les troupes soviétiques avançaient.
A ce stade, les obus pleuvaient
constamment dans les jardins de la chancellerie,
juste au-dessus du bunker.
Une série de notes dactylographiées
transcrire les discussions
entre Hitler et Goebbels
éclaire
sur les derniers espoirs militaires du Führer.
Ces documents
ont été conservés par Heinz Lorenz,
qui dirigeait le corps de presse du bunker
et ne les a publiés que récemment.
"Je peux emporter
une victoire ici à Berlin."
"Si j'obtiens cela,
même juste une victoire morale,"
"nous aurons au moins une chance
pour sauver la face et gagner du temps. »
"A Berlin, notre succès
aurait eu une portée mondiale. »
"Un tel succès ne peut être obtenu qu'ici,
où les yeux du monde sont braqués. »
"Un renversement n'est possible que si j'ai réussi
pour empêcher le colosse bolchevique.
"Alors d'autres pourraient conclure que"
"le seul capable d'arrêter
le Colosse, c'est moi",
"le parti et l'Etat allemand".
Toutes ces armées soviétiques
avançaient de manière concentrique
vers le Reichstag,
et la Chancellerie, pas très loin.
Pour les civils,
l'épreuve ne finissait jamais.
Vous imaginez les caves,
totalement emballé, pas d'eau, pas de téléphone.
La nourriture devenait un problème dramatique.
Quand un cheval fut tué dans la rue,
les gens ont risqué leur vie
se précipiter pour couper un morceau de viande.
Au milieu de ce déluge de feu,
une femme, un as de l'armée de l'air allemande,
a réussi à faire atterrir son avion
à côté du bunker d'Hitler.
C'était le 27 avril
et a confirmé la nazie Hanna Reitsch,
et son amant, le général Ritter von Greim
Je voulais voir Hitler de toute urgence.
Ils sont descendus dans le bunker,
Ritter von Greim allongé sur une civière.
Il avait reçu une balle dans le pied
alors qu'ils atterrissaient.
Pourquoi est-elle venue ?
Pour tenter de persuader Hitler
quitter le bunker,
et aller peut-être à Berchtesgaden.
Mais il ne fallait évidemment rien faire.
Naturellement, il a refusé.
[Audio parlé en allemand]
Ces derniers jours, Hitler avait distribué
des pilules de cyanure à son entourage,
il a également offert une capsule à Hanna Reitsch,
pour qu'ils puissent mettre fin à leurs jours.
C'était aussi symbolique,
un signe d'honneur pour elle.
Il la récompensait pour son exploit.
Capsule de cyanure pour Hanna Reitsch,
et une promotion pour Ritter von Greim,
qui a été nommé commandant
de la Luftwaffe à la place de Göring.
Ils repartirent alors comme ils étaient arrivés,
décollant sous une pluie de tirs soviétiques.
Ils s’en sont sortis indemnes.
Pendant ce temps, un autre dignitaire nazi
était occupé dans les coulisses,
Henri Himmler.
Il avait quitté Berlin
juste après l'anniversaire d'Hitler.
Le ministre de l'intérieur
et le chef des SS proposa aux Alliés
la reddition inconditionnelle
de l'Allemagne nazie.
Sûr de lui-même,
Himmler a tenté de prendre le relais.
Le 28 avril,
les Alliés se moquaient de lui dans la presse.
Eisenhower a totalement refusé.
Son communiqué a été publié
dans la presse occidentale.
Hitler était hystérique.
L'homme qui avait orchestré
la solution finale pour lui,
a été dépouillé de tous ses bureaux.
Cette dernière trahison
par l'un de ses plus proches acolytes
le jeta dans une colère furieuse.
Toujours à Berlin, mais hors du bunker,
Général SS Hermann Fegelein
était l'officier de liaison de Himmler avec Hitler.
Hitler était d'humeur à se venger,
et toute l'idée
que Fegelein était prêt à quitter Berlin,
qu'il était en quelque sorte
associé à Himmler
dans ce qu'Hitler considérait comme une trahison,
signifiait qu'il était déterminé
pour qu'il soit abattu.
Général Fegelein
était également le beau-frère d'Eva Braun.
Il était marié à sa sœur Gretl,
et Hitler avait personnellement
assisté à leur mariage.
Eva Braun n'était même pas préparée
mendier pour la vie de Fegelein.
En fait, elle était horrifiée
qu'il tentait de déserter,
abandonner le Führer,
et elle n'y allait pas
abandonner le Führer.
Elle pensait que c'était un acte de lâcheté de sa part
pour tenter de s'enfuir avec sa maîtresse.
Un fait aussi que
il trahissait sa sœur
en étant infidèle
signifiait qu'elle n'avait aucune pitié pour lui.
Psychologiquement,
Hitler chancela sous le coup.
Dans une dernière conversation,
tapé et conservé
par l'attaché de presse Heinz Lorenz,
Hitler et Goebbels sans enthousiasme
discuté de la situation militaire.
Si seulement Wenck pouvait venir.
Je vais essayer de m'allonger un moment.
Je veux seulement être réveillé
si un char russe arrive au bunker.
Alors j'aurai peut-être le temps
pour prendre mes dispositions.
Maintenant c'est mon tour
obéir aux ordres du destin.
Même si je pouvais me sauver, je ne le ferais pas,
un capitaine ne quitte pas un navire en perdition.
Hitler et Goebbels pensaient
que la 12e armée du général Wenck
était sur le point de percer
les troupes russes encerclant Berlin.
C’est le contraire qui s’est produit.
A peine arrivé,
que la 12e armée s'est retirée dans le chaos.
Rumeur et faux rapport
étaient les soupapes d'échappement du peuple.
Par exemple, le 28 avril,
des tracts pleuvaient sur Berlin,
annonçant l'arrivée de l'armée Wenck
du Sud-Ouest.
Une armée allemande arrive
briser l’emprise des Soviétiques ?
C'était évidemment un mensonge.
L'armée Wenck
était déjà expulsé de Potsdam.
Il n'arriverait jamais à Berlin même,
mais les gens croyaient à tout.
Après un temps est venu l'apathie, la peur, le désir
vivre une, deux, trois heures de plus.
Le 29 avril 1945,
à 1h00 du matin,
Adolf Hitler a épousé Eva Braun,
sa maîtresse depuis 13 ans.
Les seuls témoins de cette union
étaient Goebbels, Bormann et un registraire.
Un acte de mariage a été signé
par les époux et leurs témoins.
Hitler a souligné que la cérémonie
a eu lieu à la demande d'Eva Braun.
Surréaliste, compte tenu des circonstances.
Je pense qu'Hitler a décidé d'épouser Eva Braun
à cause de toute la trahison
qu'il voyait se dérouler autour de lui,
que sa décision de venir
et mourir à ses côtés,
il sentait qu'il fallait le rembourser,
et il savait qu'elle voulait,
avant tout, être Frau Hitler.
On peut aussi voir une autre signification,
confirmation qu'Hitler
avait compris que le jeu était fini.
Pourquoi?
Parce que dans des temps plus heureux, son point de vue était :
Je n'ai qu'une seule femme, l'Allemagne.
Au nom de ce grand principe,
il a refusé de se marier.
Après un verre de vin mousseux
avec Eva Braun,
et la dernière poignée
de fidèles,
Hitler se retira dans la salle de réunion,
et a appelé sa secrétaire Traudl Junge.
Il a rapidement dicté
sa volonté politique et son testament
sans hésitation ni correction.
Il n'avait rien appris
et je n'ai rien oublié.
Il y a toujours exactement les mêmes obsessions
avec les Juifs,
exactement les mêmes obsessions
qu'il n'avait jamais rien fait de mal.
Il n'a jamais commis d'erreur.
Cela avait été purement
la question de la trahison.
Nous savons qu'il était un fervent
antisémite pathologique.
J'ai été victime des deux visages
de la communauté juive internationale.
Son visage judéo-bolchevique à l’Est
et le visage de l'international
Les financiers juifs en Occident.
Alors que l'acte final
de la tragédie hitlérienne
se jouait dans le bunker,
l'Armée rouge
lance sa dernière grande offensive.
Les Soviétiques se sont arrêtés
A 500 mètres du bunker d'Hitler,
ignorant son existence.
Ils ne savaient même pas
si le Führer était toujours à Berlin.
Ils pensaient que
tous les nazis de haut rang
étaient dans le bâtiment du Parlement,
le Reichstag.
Leur objectif était le Reichstag.
En d'autres termes, il aurait pu rester
dans son bunker pendant encore quelques jours,
et personne n'aurait été plus sage.
Une fois que les Soviétiques se sont emparés du Reichstag,
ils s'attendaient à trouver
tout le gouvernement là-bas.
Ils ne l'ont pas trouvé,
mais tel était leur objectif.
Le 30 avril, dans son testament personnel,
dicté à 3 heures du matin,
Hitler a annoncé,
"Ma femme et moi choisissons la mort pour échapper
la honte de la déposition ou de la reddition.
"C'est notre souhait d'être
incinéré immédiatement là où nous reposons.
Hitler ne voulait pas avoir son cadavre
présenté comme un symbole ou comme un trophée
capturé par les Russes.
C'est pourquoi il voulait avoir son corps
et le corps d'Eva Braun ont brûlé ensemble.
J'ai trouvé dans les archives russes,
le papier,
et on pouvait voir que c'était tapé
avec le type spécial Führer pour Hitler,
décrivant la mort de Mussolini.
Hitler était déterminé à ne pas laisser son corps
pendu comme celui de Mussolini en Italie,
et je voulais avoir son corps
complètement détruit.
Au début de l'après-midi
du 30 avril 1945,
après avoir empoisonné son chien Blondi,
Hitler a dit adieu à tout son personnel.
Il a conseillé à ses assistants de se diriger vers l'Ouest,
et a exhorté ses officiers
pour continuer le combat.
Hitler et Eva Braun
se retirèrent dans leurs chambres à 15 heures.
Les corps d'Eva Braun et d'Hitler
ont été immédiatement brûlés
dans les jardins de la Chancellerie
à proximité d'une des sorties du bunker.
Le lendemain, 1er mai,
Magda et Joseph Goebbels
s'est suicidé par balle
après avoir empoisonné leurs six enfants.
La Seconde Guerre mondiale est terminée
comme cela avait commencé,
à la demande d'Adolf Hitler.
Pour sa posthume posthume,
il a choisi le grandiose
finale de masse de la bataille de Berlin.
Il s'est seulement résigné à sa propre mort
au dernier moment,
48 heures avant l'entrée des soldats soviétiques
le bunker le 2 mai 1945, à 15h00.
Les opérations militaires se sont poursuivies,
jusqu'à la signature
de la capitulation allemande
les 7 et 8 mai,
à Reims et à Berlin.
Le régime nazi
dura jusqu'au 23 mai.
Avec le départ du Führer,
la pression était retombée,
et tout s'est rapidement arrêté.
Pourtant, qu’est devenu le corps d’Hitler ?
Qui l'a trouvé en premier ?
Les agents Smash ont trouvé l'endroit
recouvert de terre,
et en dessous
les corps d'Hitler et d'Eva Braun.
Ils les ont sortis de terre,
mettez-les dans des caisses en bois
parce que les corps ont été brûlés,
mais pas complètement détruit,
et les a envoyés pour des autopsies,
et pour vérifier leurs dents.
Hitler avait un pont très particulier.
Il détestait aller chez le dentiste.
Il avait un pont totalement unique,
spécialement réalisé pour lui en or.
Une fois les restes
ont été formellement identifiés
par les services secrets soviétiques,
la création de mythes pourrait commencer.
Staline n'a pas informé le maréchal Joukov,
vainqueur de la bataille de Berlin,
de la découverte du corps d'Hitler.
Il savait qu'Hitler était mort,
mais je ne l'ai pas dit à Joukov,
ce qui signifiait que lorsque Joukov,
qui a pris le Reichstag et a été désigné,
même si Kornilov avait joué un rôle,
comme le vainqueur de Berlin.
Quand Joukov a donné
la fameuse conférence de presse
devant les journalistes rassemblés du monde entier,
il leur a dit,
"Nous n'avons pas identifié le corps d'Hitler."
"Il aurait pu s'envoler de Berlin
au tout dernier moment."
Cela n'avait aucun sens parce que Staline
savait très bien qu'il ne s'était pas envolé.
Pourtant, le monde entier
retenu cette phrase incroyable.
Et si Hitler n'était pas mort ?
Et s'il s'enfuyait ?
C'était le point de départ
pour tous les fantasmes sur le sort d'Hitler.
Depuis au moins 30 ans,
L'omission de Staline a alimenté
une littérature pseudo-historique délirante.
Des centaines de livres,
articles et témoignages,
observations enregistrées partout dans le monde,
notamment en Amérique Latine.
Pourquoi Staline a-t-il omis de mentionner
les informations sur le corps d'Adolf Hitler ?
C'était Staline qui faisait preuve de duplicité.
Il possédait une information
qu'il ne divulguerait pas
parce qu'il l'utilisait périodiquement
dans sa propagande
laisser un doute
qui pèse sur la fuite d'Hitler vers l'Ouest.
Il a soutenu sa ligne de guerre froide qui disait :
il n'y a qu'un seul pouvoir antifasciste
dans le monde,
et c'est l'Union soviétique.
La preuve en est que peut-être,
Hitler a survécu,
et est caché
par les Américains ou leurs acolytes.
C'était une arme de propagande
Et rien de plus.
Qu'est devenu le bunker ?
A-t-il été détruit ?
L'endroit où Hitler a terminé ses jours
n'est pas devenu un mémorial
pour les nostalgiques du Reich.
Après la chute du mur de Berlin en 1989,
l'Occident l'a découvert
que les anciens jardins de la Chancellerie
sous lequel le bunker a été construit
était devenu un parking pour les habitants
de ces immeubles.
Ce n'est que 70 ans plus tard,
qu'une association berlinoise
installé ces panneaux
qui fournissent un compte précis
des derniers jours d'Hitler dans le bunker.
À ce jour, les autorités soviétiques
je n'ai toujours pas donné d'explication
de ce qui a été fait avec les restes.
Quant aux documents historiques,
découvert par le commandant Rose
et Bruno Ledoux,
ils ont maintenant été rendus publics.
Ils nous permettent de compléter
quelques aspects fondamentaux
de l'histoire politique et personnelle
du plus grand criminel du 20e siècle.